this is a mod ahmad is very rich and he
wants to put that money to good use so
just a few days ago he presented
something called stable diffusion
through an initiative that he finances
called stability ai stability ai is
supposed to be a third pillar there's
industry there's academia and now
there's something else remember when
open ai started and they said they
wanted to bring ai to the masses to
democratize the technology and all that
kind of stuff well amon wants to do that
but for real so this is an interview
with ahmad he's gonna tell us what he
wants to achieve with stability ai how
he plans to go forward so that he's not
the only one that's financing this
admittedly very giant operation
currently and what you can do wherever
you might be an academic person from
industry or just someone who's
interested and wants to do something in
the ai space and you need some compute
you need some help you need some time
stability ai might be the place for you
if you haven't seen the output of stable
diffusion yet the first system coming
out of this initiative they are
absolutely amazing and not only that the
model is small and fast it runs on a
consumer gpu and it creates pictures in
about three seconds and the model is
released open source fully up to you
what to do with it very cool so i don't
want to stretch this intro too long
please listen to what emma has to say
i'm sure you'll be very interested
hey everyone today i'm here with ahmad
mustack who is
uh i have to say uh i
was contacted by mod through a mutual
friend and it was very intriguing so all
i know is that emote wants to tell us
about exciting opportunities essentially
an alternative in research to bigger
labs and big companies doing research a
essentially a third door a third path of
people having access to resources to do
current deep learning research iman
welcome what brings you here uh hi annik
i think that we're at a super exciting
time in artificial intelligence
everything seems like
it's about to take off um and i'm here
to say
you know let's all come together and
make sure that it gets out to as many
people as possible and we unlock all the
creativity that people have in front of
them so basically i set up an
organization called stability ai to
remove many of the barriers for
independent and academic researchers
to build some of these new models that
we're seeing um kind of in the early
days of luther lives and others we heard
that compute and kind of funding were a
key restriction
so everyone has basically three choices
you go into academia you don't have
compute access and then you have to jump
to big tech and then you have 59-page
ndas and you work in a corporate
environment for product teams or you
have your own startup and really running
your own startup is terrible and it's
not something for most academics
or researchers although of course some
of them will hopefully be very
successful doing legal ai and things
like that
um
i thought there was going to be a better
way because this type of technology that
we're seeing 80 percent of research
dollars is going into
next generation ai
and it really has the potential to
improve humanity
um and so that's why with stability i
basically said can we solve compute can
we solve funding and can we bring people
together to build cool stuff
and we've actually achieved and managed
that when we go uh live on the 8th of
august i don't know if this will be
before or after i think hopefully after
all will be revealed but i'm happy to
discuss everything that we've done today
to address these and what's coming down
the pipeline so you say solve compute
solve funding essentially means money
so
stability ai
what's the source of funding or what's
the money flow into this organization
and how is that money spent so initially
it was primarily my funding
so i was lucky enough to have a good
career as a hedge fund manager then in
2020 2021 i led the collective and
augmented intelligence against clover 19
initiative launch at stanford to use the
port 19 data sets and the backing of the
who unesco and world bank to
organize the world's covered knowledge
and make it understandable um so i've
got lots of connections so i pull them
together primary my own kind of funding
and basically what we've done is uh
we've got a 4000 a100 cluster for open
source artificial intelligence
uh with the support of amazon but no
control by them
uh so that ranks above jules booster as
potentially the 10th fastest public
supercomputer
and uh luther ai and lion
have been basically building on top of
that some of the most cool models that
i've ever seen that are about to be
released across modalities i was about
to say uh kind of we've done so we've
done this as a community to date uh the
next stage is even more exciting we're
partnering up with countries and leading
institutions to take this to the next
level farm will compute far more funding
and most of all coordination
so that again
intelligence and creativity can be
unlocked to build systems
both for countries communities and you
know for humanity that are open and not
closed
is there a comparison to maybe something
that exists it could could it be
compared to something like cern or the
international space station what is it
that you're aiming for when you say
we're going for countries we're going
for collaboration so we're already
partnered with the united nations we're
doing national level partnerships with
for example uh
leading groups institutions from india
to singapore to others from universities
to leading media conglomerates
telcos the governments themselves to
build national level models and data
sets um so we have the plurality of kind
of being around this kind of uh this is
kind of like we kicked it off as cern
but from a discord group probably
through ai and then it evolved into lion
open by ml and a bunch of these others
bring together really talented
researchers and then mine and my team's
responsibility was to get the resources
they needed to unlock this the next
stage is a bit more institutional but we
really hope it keeps this kind of
community vibe
that we've got and this community
structure that we've built community
vibe i think is a is a good key word uh
there are people who just come forward
by themselves who want to build things
who are quite clearly engaged a lot of
people in the luther ai also
people from lyon
yet
when it i think gets more public that
there is a lot of money that there is uh
you know funding compute and so on
there is potentially going to be an
influx of a lot of people with a lot of
ideas and promises how do you select who
gets access to your resources and what
can be done with it
so currently i am gpu emperor so kind of
i decide which projects and things go
forward uh that's not sustainable so
instead what we're doing is we're again
without trying to kill the vibe places
like a luther lion open by ml and other
communities that we've got coming for
audio and contrastive learning robotics
etc
set up processes by which grants can be
given quickly for small research and
then we can really think about what the
bigger runs and things like that are all
about uh with a focus and a mission of
you know what's cool and what's useful
for humanity
um stability ai itself on the other side
you know we are kind of commercializing
these we are a for-profit entity but
with a mission-based thing so benefit
corporation
um and that will inform some of it um
but not all of it so it's this balance
of how do you have r d
and academic and independent and then
how do you productize that so it gets to
a billion people um and we've got a very
interesting case study that cracks next
week around that and i'll have to
discuss with stable diffusion
what is stable diffusion
stable diffusion is the last of this
series of kind of diffusion models with
them it's the one that basically breaks
through on quality speed and
cost
to enable anyone to create images so
dally 2 was a fantastic experience
stable diffusion is about 30 times more
efficient and runs on a consumer
graphics card for daily 2 level image
quality
so this was a combination of various
groups such as confess from heidelberg
who came up with bq gan and latent
diffusion um our lead generative ai
coder catherine krausen rivers have
wings
kind of a whole range of other kind of
famous characters in the community to
say how can we build an efficient model
that can scale to a billion people to
enable them to be creative and so that
releases touchwood on the 8th or 9th of
august and we'll be releasing an open
source along with instructions how to
run it locally in the cloud and others
so
what we've got is you know dream
you see some gal gadot's there right
tesla roadster on the
street so where are you yannick
zurich switzerland streets of zurich
right
you don't even need to dream that up the
streets here are filled with teslas
right
um basically uh kind of
dally 2 is
sorry my internet's a bit slow maybe
we'll redo this demo than faster
internet
basically this generates images in about
three seconds on 5 gigabytes of vram
whereas other image models required like
40 gigabytes or 20 gigabytes of vram and
they're super slow so now it's my
internet that's actually slower than the
actual box
so maybe we'll redo that demo in a bit
uh
well there we see it's coming so i'm on
dial up right now it seems um
that gives me nostalgia feelings i have
to say the the line by line rendering of
images
rendering of images exactly it's uh
pretty fun
if you're watching this and you're
younger than 25 this is what the
internet was like in the early days
that's an interesting so there you got
your lovely tesla in zurich right
um but you know this is an image model
that we built off lion5b uh the lion
guys were obviously here a while ago
very close kind of working with us some
of them are actually stability employees
as well you know taking that 250
terabytes of data we can press it down
to two gigabytes kind of via this
diffusion model type of thing
i mean by the time this goes out
probably everyone will be able to play
with it locally or kind of in the cloud
etc because we really want to unlock
this wave of innovation you know because
i think that's how it happens
like i don't know if luke has made the
announcement yet but gpt neo and gpt vox
and j have been downloaded 25 million
times now by developers right
that can really catalyze ecosystems for
development
against you know the more sorry say
paternalistic instincts
of some of the bigger ai players who
refuse to release images like model the
code or the weights
um it's like system diffusion is a very
interesting one um because we could have
kept it close source
you know it's a step forward it's 30
times more efficient than value 2. you
have comparable image quality and you
know you saw the raw output
but why would you if you could instead
make it go from millions of people using
this technology to billions of people
using this technology that's far more
interesting
and again i think this is the type of
thing we need to do make this technology
really usable so don't think 175 billion
parameter language models or 540 billion
parameter models are really usable for
the vast majority of humanity
so you you mentioned this open source
closed source paternalistic and so on i
agree there is a paternalistic element
but there's also a pr and a legal
element right if dolly 2 was accessible
to everyone and so on and people find oh
i just need to enter this prompt to make
it produce something that's that's
really horrible that may produce a
backlash right saying well these models
are clearly not fit for release and so
on
what is your sort of opinion if someone
comes to you and says your model
produces horrible output here i've i can
show you uh
what do you say to those people
i would say of course humanity is
horrible and they use technology in
horrible ways in good ways as well
but the reality is for this particular
output the vast majority of people are
creatively constipated
we have been conditioned to consume
constantly by social media and big tech
giants and they want us to consume more
according to their parameters
we see a model like this like a three or
we've had three year olds use it in
refugee camps all the way to 90 year
olds you know we're putting in mental
health settings i think the benefits far
outweigh any negativity and the reality
is that people need to get used to these
models because they're coming one way or
another
and restricting them means that you
become the arbiter so as an example we
took some
programmers out of russia
because they spoke out against the
government there you know and they came
some came from the ukraine as well and
we fast tracked their residency in the
uk
you can't use the word ukraine in delhi
too
you know because it's political then as
well if you type in sumo wrestler they
randomly add into the prompts because
they do pre-prompt and post-prompt
processing
a diversity filter so you get asian
female symbol wrestlers because they
randomly add ethnicities there's nothing
you can do about that right
if you want to create a localized
version
that you know is more respective to your
culture for example in india you can't
do that because you can't access the
model right and they don't have the
capacity to let you fine tune it
so instead what they're saying is ai for
us and our clients because it's
expensive to run these things
not for everyone else you know what
they're really saying is we don't trust
you as humanity because we know better i
think that's wrong you know i actually
trust people i trust them to be weird
and nasty in some cases because you know
one percent point one percent of people
are weird many people on this call are
weird you know i'm weird but at the same
time like i said i think that this is
positive technology for humanity and
should diffuse because then the pace of
innovation to make it beneficial as well
as to combat negative uses is far
greater
you previously said stability ai
employee so not only do you give grants
in terms of hardware and what to run you
do
pay people to actually work part-time or
full-time can you specify a little bit
of what
just the what being an employee at
stability ai means
yeah so you know different people need
different things we come from all
diverse backgrounds some of them needed
the equivalent to their jobs at google
or microsoft when they left so we pay
competitive salaries high bonuses
and in our contract no ip
all the work can be open sourced by any
developer um similarly we have set it up
so as we run apis and our models there's
a revenue share for all developers even
if they don't work at stability who
created the models
so 10 of revenue goes to this pool half
of which goes to the creators of the
models and data sets and half of which
goes to a communal pool where everyone
involved in stability as an employee or
otherwise which i'll come to in a second
basically awards it's the most
interesting research
so that you can actually have a career
from
you know doing interesting research for
open source and it doesn't have to be
commercial you know so the commercial is
the running the apis the non-commercial
is under five percent of revenue
we also do
um fellowships so we're sponsoring a
whole bunch of coders such as lucid
drains for wang through github sponsors
and we ask what do you need to be
comfortable
we're gonna fund a hundred phds in ai
over the next year and that comes with
compute for academia uh small and large
as well and we hope that will be a
community within our communities and
across communities that can coordinate
global academic research and we support
as well so for example we have mental
health support we have grant writers we
have paper writers and other things just
to enable people to get on with what's
interesting and be able to build in the
open uh we haven't been in the open
until now because we've been building
and also because it's quite fun to
announce and release all this um but we
hope that we can actually build in the
open and change some of these incentive
structures by unlocking people be it
grants be it fellowships be a phd
funding be it part-time jobs full-time
jobs or just being members of the
community and getting prizes from this
kind of pool that will hopefully become
very large
we also have a charity as well and
that's where the phd funding relevant
comes from so charitable
what um keeps you from becoming
like going the same route as let's say
open ai
any
all these companies from deepmind they
have it you know we want to make ai for
everyone
they've been for-profit and very closed
from the beginning opena actually
started out with we want to democratize
we want everyone to be accessible to
give us money and we we know what's good
for you right what keeps you like
there's there's clearly a pull right
there's clearly demands coming with any
money that flows in
it's clearly attractive to sort of keep
your
let's say leading position to attract
more researchers and so on how do you
prevent yourself from
let's say succumbing to that pull of
going close towards going profit well i
think it
you know open ai one of the founders
who's left everyone mentioned on this
call maybe we can mention it privately
said that kind of what we're creating is
what he wanted to do when opening i was
founded
it was just the wrong time so obviously
you know they had to scale up compute
because you have this kind of stack more
layers type thing
um and then all the issues that happened
in 2019 eon musk etc that basically led
to a bailout and they're changing the
entire corporate structure
um and then a change in focus they
become more productive even though
they're not actually product focused
uh deep mind had a bit of a different
kind of thing but again they were the
wrong time because what you've seen is
these models have lots of promise and
they're powerful but they haven't had
that technological diffusion curve right
what is the killer app
natural language processing and kind of
these large language models they were
tackling a problem i think was already
85 to 90 solved and now we've gone to 95
solved and they're large and bulky
image i think is the killer app because
when you look at this
it's a wonder for people they can
suddenly create rather consume
and that's something that's across the
board you know the comparatives are
snapchat or tick tock where you can
create there's pokemon go you know gacha
games and these kinds of things but
it'll be integrated into so many
different areas it's got fast enough
cheap enough and good enough and like i
said like this model file that we're
releasing only a couple of gigabytes you
know it can fit on eight gigabytes of
vram that's crazy
you know like there'll be bigger models
and better models like imogen but this
inflection point is what makes our
business sustainable it allows us to do
things like say you can work just for
open source to our employees it allows
us to do things like revenue share where
we'll be able to attract the best
employees because if you believe this is
going to a billion people you'll have
more than that
and then finally the structure that
we've employed is kind of one whereby
we're partnering with
various kind of governments and leading
institutions so that we build ai for
each nation and communities in each
nation so we capture that cultural
diversity so again it's very community
focused it's right oriented there's a
good business model we've negotiated
massive deals so we'd be profitable at
the door versus most money losing big
corporations
there's a few extra things in there that
i can't discuss right now
but we really kind of laid out to be the
right company at the right time to
coordinate this all and then hopefully
as this goes this becomes an independent
more decentralized thing
originally we wanted to be web 3 with
tokens and all that but you don't need
that you know you just need to have a
good community that keeps you in check
and you need to build in the open and do
things in the open which i hope will
manage to do over the next year
how can
people
find you how can people find your models
and work with your stuff and how can
people who are maybe interested in in
taking part in the community and and
contributing in some way find you
um so we have our website stability ai
that will be updated when we launch
publicly next week um you know join our
communities at luther ai or lyon or
others that we're going to accelerate
and really
you know put a lot more structure around
open biomel harmonize for music carp for
contrastive learning you know we've got
education and many other things coming
down the pipeline um
yeah i think it's just community-based
be active in the community you will get
rewarded with you know money and status
and all sorts of other things if you do
interesting stuff you want to join
stability there are roles for
exceptional programmers to come and help
coordinate this you want your phd funded
we will announce the phd funding program
in a couple of months
you know um you want to tell us how to
do this properly open to advice
you know like i don't think we have all
the answers but i hope we're kind of
getting there and i think certainly will
make a difference through this really
flexible supercomputer cluster if
nothing else again it's a big big
cluster
and it's available for the coolest
research that can make an impact on
humanity
and we'll get more we have far bigger
supercompute
as well so i think that's super exciting
what is the type of person that you're
looking for in a contributor and what is
maybe a type of person that you're not
looking for so the type of person
looking for a contributor are those that
believe in open source ai and
not open source energy but you know open
source innovation you know like we're
bringing this technology to make
humanity better you can make profits
that's fine right but i think it should
be secondary to just is this going to
make a difference
you know i don't mind if people are
corporate etcetera but it needs to be
people that integrate with the community
can work well with people from a whole
bunch of different backgrounds and just
are generally inquisitive that want to
push the boundaries um i think some of
the biggest breakthroughs we've had have
been from non-traditional backgrounds
you know i don't know if you've
interviewed the luther ai founders none
of them have a computer science degree
you know um and yet they kind of managed
to achieve such great things now
obviously there's conjecture for
alignment and we're pushing some of the
capability stuff there
so you know i think what we don't want
to see is just people who are just
highly corporatized kind of stuck in one
way of thinking
and want to see how to make a quick buck
out of all of this i think you can make
money but so what we're at this pivotal
point where this technology can maximize
humanity's potential
or it can be corporatized and be used as
a method of centralization and control
which side do you want to be on
yeah
now you can make money on both sides
um is there
anything else that you want to get out
to people that you want to let people
know that we haven't talked about yet uh
no i mean like i said we've got an
amazing pipeline and roadmap that we
have to put out and open so you know
work on everything from audio diffusion
video diffusion 3d
i mean i think in particular if people
want to try and create the metaverse the
ready player one one minus the micro
transaction or holodeck we're gonna
aiming to do that and i would say that
probably our killer out the one that i
want to make most and i'd invite anyone
to contact me if they want to build this
with me is i want to destroy powerpoint
i think the combination of language
image kind of contrastive and other
models means that if we work super hard
in a few years we'll never need to make
a slide deck again
tell the computer tell it how you want
to adjust it they'll be beautiful each
time and think about how much happiness
will bring to the world that way
no more no more stock images of of
little drawn people going like hmm
very cool
yeah you know dragging and dropping
little bits on the slides and you know
refining them just tell the computer
it'll create the slide deck for you
tell it how you want to adjust it it
will adjust it so much happiness brought
to the world
um i think that's another thing as well
like
academia
um companies all these things i think
too many people in our community are
unhappy
and obviously there's a lot of neuro
atypical people within our community
right i'm neuro-atypical myself you know
um i wanna see how we can have a happier
community that supports each other
because otherwise there are these big
highs and lows and things like that i
don't think people focus enough on that
that's what i focus on with my engineers
and what i'm trying to focus on the
community uh because then people will be
more productive sure but they've also
been more content so
it sounds a bit fuzzy but i think it's
really important and people don't pay
enough attention to it wise words
so i should maybe mention one of the
projects we have seven cups
sevencups.com
um it's something that we help kind of
accelerate you can go and you can chat
to someone so you don't even have the
pressure of talking to someone online
who's been trained in active listening
um and we have studies showing this is
effective is taking prozac
but then and it's free and for 150 a
month you can talk to a part-time mental
health therapist
so
we've got 468 000 volunteers in 180
countries uh helping 80 million people
each month so i'd recommend people try
that and then if anyone wants to help me
take that data set
you know with full privacy and
everything like that to create systems
that we can better listen and understand
each other uh again that's something
that i'd be very interested in talking
to people because i really want to help
people help people awesome
hey mark thank you very much for being
here very exciting i'm looking forward
to the release uh next week maybe it's
already out once this is out uh yeah
thanks a lot for being here and good
luck to the endeavor thank you very much
jenny pleasure awesome podcast you've
had i've enjoyed listening to it thank
you
[Music]